what's good y'all this is jay park aomg
high music and i'm going to be reading
some thirsty ass tweets from you thirsty
ass fans here on buzzfeed
[Music]
first tweet jay park could breathe
oxygen and someone in the crowd would
tear their underwear off maybe i've had
a lot of instances in
where i've been performing and i didn't
get a lot of
underwear slash undergarments it's
flattering for me
to say the least the last time the earth
was that hot
was jay park's last concert right after
he took off his shirt
guessing these fans are a little bit
younger i really want jay park to grab
my butt
and call me baby girl is that too much
to ask
it is not too much to ask at all it
depends on how old you are though
don't want to get myself in trouble jay
park makes the best sex music
i-s-t-g what does that mean what's the
stg everybody here
is old so they don't know jay park makes
the best sex music i
stg i'm getting turned on just listening
to it i grew up listening to a lot of
slow jams
r b brian mcknight boys man drew hill
it just comes very natural to me
um to make those kind of more sensual
sexual r b
songs it is flattering to know that you
guys
do enjoy that type of music so i will
continue to do that type of music
maybe until i retire or become a dad or
something like that i don't know the
first thing a woman looks at
in a man is his heart the fact that jay
park cities
are in front of his heart is not my
fault oh that's a good one
likewise me after seeing jay park city's
irl i don't know that means earl
oh in real life oh those double d's
really do bounce and the sweat drips off
them like
rain in heaven damn you guys are
i've been uh working out since uh a very
young age
and that's why i guess my chest area is
more
you know enhanced than my other body
parts if you think that i would walk
through a fiery pit of glass and then
jump into a pool of hand sanitizer just
to get the chance to lick jay park sweat
you are absolutely right
that sounds like a game show let's make
it happen thinking about
jay park's thick tits
oh man i'm glad i wore a very tight
shirt today the expression thick tits is
very new to me it rolls off the tongue
very nice thick tits
i like that i really want jay park to
ruin my [ __ ] life i wanted to i
wanted to control everything i do
and keep a damn gps on me i'll stay on
my knees
oh my gosh these these i could be a very
very bad man if i wanted to
but i'm a very nice guy so i would just
read these tweets and
be entertained i'd let jay park bend me
over backwards and punt me like a
football
bend me over backwards is that like
this way you must be very flexible you
must be like a contortionist i don't
know i
i wouldn't feel comfortable punting you
like a football jay park
i'm just a hole sir
i just leave it at that all right all
right so when it when am i getting
cuffed by jay park
the man could destroy me with this pinky
toe and i'd say it again all right this
is not too bad
cuffed what that's just like you know
cuffing season i'm thinking
it's not like handcuffed or anything
sexual like that no yeah this is not too
bad
me jay park is thick my friend he is
thick with a double c and no k at all i
guess that's the kind of the
expression that the uh the younger
people are using these days no k
double c i like it it looks nice uh
wow are all i need to watch some of
these buzzfeed thirst tweets i wonder if
everybody else's fans or their tweets
are this x-rated
i want jay park to rip my butt
i don't even know what to say to that
starting to get a little bit disturbed
are these real tweets so yeah that was
thirst tweets uh with buzzfeed
and jay park shout outs to all the fans
hope you are staying safe and healthy
i enjoy your tweets i'm entertained by
it higher music just came out with the
compilation
uh september 2nd the red tape september
16th
the blue tape so make sure y'all check
it out i'm on almost every song shout
out to y'all
[Music]
buzzfeed
[Music]
you